[Music]
in the Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild they are a number of important
mechanics and concepts that the game
never explains outright at times the
game alludes to them but the majority of
the time you're left to figure them out
on your own either by experimenting or
completing a side quest that introduces
a particular mechanic with so many
veiled secrets we've compiled nine
useful things to know to help you on
your journey
be wary there are potential spoilers
ahead if you enjoy this video be sure to
LIKE and subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more features on breath of
the wild for a rundown on the game's
basics check out our in-depth beginner's
guide video number one how to perform a
perfect dodge parry and charged attack
against the tough enemy there are three
advanced and essential combat techniques
perfect dodge parry and the charged
attack perfect dodge allows you to slow
down time after a precise dodge and
inflict a devastating flurry attack upon
an enemy to execute a perfect dodge jump
out of the way of an attack right before
it's about to hit you and then press Y
to perform the attack flurry parry
allows you to use your shield to deflect
an enemy's blow leaving it vulnerable to
an immediate counter-attack to parry
lock onto an enemy and press a right
before their attack connects the charged
attack allows you to perform a powerful
offensive maneuver each weapon type
sports a different charge attack for
instance the sword is a 360-degree
attack that covers you on all sides
while the spear has a flurry of stabs to
use a charged attack simply hold the
wide button in combat
[Music]
number two how to shield board it's
possible to use your shield to slide
down hills and steep inclines to do so
hold zl2 bring up your shield then jump
for it and press a as you slide on your
shield you can shoot arrows or press the
Y button to perform tricks note that
sliding on your shield wears down its
durability so use this ability wisely
number three how to catch a horse if you
want to travel faster through Hyrule
you should find and tame a horse the
best place to get a horse early on is at
the Black Sheep Lane where there are
several roaming free there are two types
of horses to discover spotted and one
color spotted horses are great for
beginners as they're easier to tame and
aren't as a tempered one color horses
are more difficult to tame and are often
unwilling to follow your directions but
their higher stamina and speed more than
make up for the grief to tame a horse
sneak up to one and hop onto its back
and then mash the L button to soothe it
before it kicks you off after you've
earned the horses respect take it to the
nearest stable to register it this
allows you to summon it whichever stable
you're at if you get separated if you
want your horse to perform at its very
best you need to be attentive to its
performance when a cooperates make sure
to reward it by soothing it or feeding
it an apple but keep in mind it's
imperative to soothe your horse when
it's panicked or stressed number 4 you
can upgrade your armor if you go up the
hill from the shrine in Kakariko village
you'll find a plant pod in a forest
clearing hidden inside the pod is the
great fairy Katara who requests 100
rupees from you to reawaken her power
if you oblige she can upgrade your armor
using components you find out in the
world for example to enhance the Hylian
tunic you need to give her back Adlon
horns it's important to note that an
armor set gains a special bonus after
Katara enhances each part twice
number five you can grab fairies it's
possible to grab fairies floating in the
air doing so turns them into a useable
item which can revive you when your
health fully depletes as a result
fairies are a precious commodity that
shouldn't be wasted you can typically
find fairies near any of the three great
fairy fountains or hiding in tall grass
number six you can reassign your heart
containers and stamina vessels in Hatano
village you can find a mopey lookin
statue at the bottom of the hill on the
other side of the village entrance if
you talk to it you'll initiate a side
quest but the statue steal some of your
essence speak to it again to reclaim
what was taken from you the statue
offers you a deal where you can sell it
one of your heart containers or stamina
vessels for a 100 rupees this might
sound like a bad trade-off at first but
you're actually able to talk to it again
and pay 120 rupees to acquire either a
heart container or a stamina vessel in
return this is a handy resource as
you're essentially paying 20 rupees to
reassign the upgrades you've acquired
throughout your journey number 7 you can
expand your inventory space on your way
to Kakariko village you encounter a
giant Kuro
named Heston who pleads with you to
retrieve its maracas from a pack of
mccollins completing this task earns you
the ability to upgrade your inventory
space but at a cost Hess who asks that
you supply him with karoku seeds he can
use to fix his now broken maracas these
special seeds can only be acquired by
finding kur oak hidden in the
environment for example you can find one
hidden beneath a rock on top of one of
the pillars of levia for every kerr oak
seed you bring hesti he'll upgrade the
space of an inventory category of your
choice keep an eye out for anything that
seems out of place in the environment if
something seems amiss chances are that
there's a kuroky hiding there
[Music]
number eight you can buy a house when
you enter Hatano you can find a group of
construction workers attempting to tear
down the house near the village shrine
if you talk to their head Foreman bolson
he'll ask you if you want to purchase
the house accept his offer to strike a
deal to acquire the house for a sum of
three thousand rupees and 30 bundles of
wood after buying the house bolson can
furnish it with various upgrades for
example you can ask him to install a
door or to make you a bed you can use to
rest overnight however each upgrade is
going to cost you 100 rupees number 9
you can dye your clothes in Hatano
village the second shop to the right
allows you to dye your clothes various
colors for the cost of 20 rupees
you also need five items that share in
the dye color you wish to use these can
be any materials you find out in the
wild keep in mind the shopkeeper dyes
your entire outfit the color you choose
so it's best to mix and match what you
want colored for more efficient use of
your money but if you change your mind
about the colors you choose you can
always revert back to the original color
scheme for another 20 rupees if there's
anything we missed
shout it in the comments below and for
more coverage on The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild go check out our full
review
[Music]